I was I was I was in college and I was
one of those first credit cards you get
not really knowing a lot and ran up my
credit card debt quite a bit how I me
essentially paid for my own credit paid
for my college experience but
regretfully not understanding interest
rates in compound interest penalties and
you know MIT minimum payments don't last
forever that that was the big big
mistake and i hope to educate as many
people as possible to not get the same
trap you know coming out of that I've
learned all lot around how credit cards
working how the credit card and she
actually is a profitable industry for me
now it's how do I get the most out of my
knowledge and I travel a lot I use my
credit card lot and some kind of getting
back by making chef best credit card in
my wallet being shown her anything most
amount of points